for the iconic role of Joker and Suicide
Squad Jared Leto got into incredible
shape and focused on building serious
muscle definition now he's hitting the
gym again to get ready to star as the
title character in the upcoming
spider-man spin-off film Morbius the
personal training sessions for Suicide
Squad were no joke under the guidance of
trainer Brendan Johnston the entire cast
got bit together while staying at a
training facility in Toronto for what
they described as boot camp Johnston had
specific exercises in mind for each cast
member depending on what their character
would be doing on-screen according to
Men's Journal Johnston wanted Leto to
look like an MMA fighter by the time he
was done working with him how did he
achieve that for starters
letõs regular workouts consisted of
plenty of bodybuilding exercises and
weighted calisthenics he also practiced
boxing and Johnson noted that Leto was
quote throwing a lot of punches
throughout the day letõs regular
routines also included daily cardio the
cast typically got one day off after
every four days they spent in the gym so
there was also some mandatory rest time
Leto is living proof that you don't need
to eat meat in order to build muscle
according to an interview with GQ Leto
has been beacon for over two decades
clearly it's working out pretty well for
him as he credits his vegan lifestyle
for his health he does admit to cheating
every once in a while and indulging in
treats that contain milk or eggs but he
draws the line at consuming meat even on
special occasions a vegan chef comes on
tour with thirty Seconds to Mars even
when the band did their carnivores to
her with Linkin Park Leto was still
fueling up on fruits and vegetables
backstage in 2014 he was named pitas
sexiest vegan to get ready to play the
Joker
Leto had to eat every two hours
throughout the day to keep his energy up
and his metabolism working hard
so what's letõs number one fitness
secret his primary piece of advice is
something that seems so obvious yet many
people still underestimate its
importance when it comes to looking your
best Leto told Rolling Stone I would
tell everyone to sleep as much as you
can with his crazy schedule he knows
that it's crucial to get that full eight
hours of sleep every night from concerts
to the gym to the recording studio to
the set of whatever film he's working on
he needs to be able to perform at his
best every moment of the day some people
assume that musicians and actors would
rather go out every night and crawl into
bed early but roulette okthis
the case it's easy to assume that an
actor who dives deeply into their roles
like Leto might be experimenting with
certain substances off screen after all
he did live on the street with addicts
to prepare for his role in requiem for a
dream but even then Leto didn't for take
and he says that at this point he's been
totally straightedge for many years no
drugs or alcohol Leto admitted to
getting into some trouble in his younger
days due to his previous alcohol and
drug use however he eventually changed
his ways and he knows that he made the
right choice he told Rolling Stone I
guess at some point too there's a
decision is this going to be my life I
made a choice to pursue other dreams the
risk versus reward is out of line I just
saw too many examples of what not to do
Leto hasn't yet given any specific
details about his workouts for Morbius
however he does post pretty frequently
on Instagram so far it looks like he's
been working out on his elliptical and
he also says he's been going for daily
morning bike rides even while he's on
tour of course Torian is a workout in
and of itself it's kind of like you know
a master he knows spinning aerobics
class Richard Simmons would be proud of
course Torian is a workout in itself
although he hasn't posted about any
bodybuilding workouts yet he's most
likely sticking with the lifting routine
as well rock climbing is also one of
letõs favorite hobbies whether he's
trying to get in shape for a particular
role or not he always makes time to
climb he told Rolling Stone climbing is
also a form of stress relief for him and
a way to stay balanced in the chaotic
world of Hollywood
Morbius isn't due out for release until
July 2020 was shooting having commenced
in March 2019
but you can bet with his unmatched
commitment to his work Leto assured to
deliver us the star check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]